[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and she is going to talk to you more
about makes me so happy
[Applause]
they're going to tell you stories all of
these stories are
[Applause]
thanks very much so I'm gonna talk to
you today about the biggest scientific
failure I've ever had as Kate said I
just joined Rockefeller mannan gorgeous
when I was doing my undergraduate I
entered a competition with some friends
and the competition was called - my gem
the International genetically engineered
machine sounds free grounded very
complicated but really what it's about
is getting students high school students
sometimes I'm university students to
design and build useful genetically
modified and I think it's more colorful
if I sort of explain or just give you
some examples of the sort of things that
people have done and the sorts of things
that people managed to do in the year
that I entered the competition so one of
the finalists in the competition built a
bacterial fridge so you could use
bacteria grow bacteria in a little
polystyrene box on a medium you've just
given it some nutrients let it grow in a
box and it makes the box Pole so when
you're trying to ship something we
wanted you be cold a new innovative way
of keeping it cold is the bacteria
there were people who built a fruit
ripening sensor something which detects
gasses and misses by fruit as they ripen
in your fruit bowl so you can have a
little bio detector in your fruit bowl
and it will change color and the
bacteria will go green when the fruit is
ready when your bananas are ready which
i think is quite a nice thing I
constantly have a problem with unripe or
overripe bananas so this would be a very
very useful anyway my team wanted to do
is to build a sensor and it's a sense of
the lactose I don't know if anybody here
is lactose intolerant there's a few
people who are lactose intolerant so we
we hear you we feel you we wanted to
build something to improve your lives
and so what we try to do is build a semi
which is a fancy way of just saying
orange and then a lot carry around a
little bag which may seem like a rather
food now but at the time I was so
excited and I could see franchise
developing not detectors seafood
detectors and other people things if you
have allergies to I thought it was gonna
be extremely useful and life-changing
which probably almost certain is untrue
anyway so we tried it we try to build it
and we failed at every single step of
the process we failed to even get our
DNA or modified DNA into
bacteria so the bacteria ended up just
throwing normally without our DNA in it
depressing and this is after we had
failed repeatedly to be able to even to
assemble the DNA we wanted to put inside
bacteria so the DNA we wanted to put
inside encodes this but we couldn't do
anything with it so at the end of the
project I had spent three months of my
summer trying to do this with three
other freshman at college and we and the
soundest part was everybody around us
had really really wonderful projects so
people had as I said built amazing
things bacterial fridges through
rivaling senses someone who even built a
little bacteria you could put into a
polluted lake and it would help clear up
the lake yeah that's kind of cool
and I had a plate of unmodified back
together it's the same as what I had at
the beginning of the project we missed
the conference event there was a
conference event everybody to present
their work we of course didn't have
anything to present so we missed it and
I at the time felt like it was a
disaster three years later I applied to
grad school and I'm gonna read you the
first line from my application it says
my first real encounter with
experimental biology was my freshman
college I gen project where I and a
group of three others designed and tried
to build a lactose bio detector we
failed and the whole process was
probably the most difficult thing I'd
ever done and then I went on to talk
about some other science things and
hopefully tell the admissions committee
at the various colleges that I applied
to that I didn't always fail at
everything so I applied to nine colleges
this was in my application to all of
them and the reason it was in there was
because it was genuinely a really really
important lesson that I learned you can
try really hard and not succeed and
that's okay you just pick yourself up
get on with it
and try something else we'll try again
we'll get help
and now of course in a actual science
lab but I'm doing these sorts of things
everyday the whole thing seems trivial
right I can easily get DNA into bacteria
that I work with now I can easily
assemble any constructs that I want to
assemble now so in a way I had the last
laugh
maybe I'll recreate the entry just three
years late um so yeah that's what I
wanted to tell you about I guess finally
what I'll say is that just today I have
set up four or five different things in
the lab and three of them failed that's
just something that happens it happens
on a daily basis I don't necessarily
know why they failed I just try again
and sometimes they were and hopefully
when I'm a fourth-year the failure rate
will come down I don't know if that's
true guys they tell me no anyway there
you go thank you very much for listening
and yeah next next up I'm sorry I did
maybe like three experiments this week
so that is part of science but it
doesn't mean that we don't learn just
because things fail we learn from them
sometimes things fail and it's not your
fault it's also good to know how to deal
with failure when maybe it is your fault
maybe it isn't your fault but there's
nothing maybe you can do about it and to
deal with the fear of failure so our
next speaker is gonna talk about how she
deals with the fear of failure and how
many things she could be afraid of at
one time she's amazing I loved her story
and is super inspirational to me and
maybe I will take her up on her advice
maybe you will too
so our next speaker is Shuba and she is
a postdoc in the Kapur lab here at
Rockefeller so welcome Shuba
hello I'm a scientist so it doesn't drop
I finished that school but I failed
three experiments this week and I think
I still have the weekend to go and I
don't know how much more will fail so
yeah we face failures on an everyday
basis and the bad news is that the
failure rate doesn't go down and it's
only gonna get worse as you grow older
and
disappeared so but the good thing is
they can be tackled and the bad thing is
you feels more fears and better and
today we tell you a very short story of
how I learnt to tackle my fears and how
I evolved strategies with time so when I
was in the audience a cup about high
school the worst nightmares we're about
my exams like failing my exams like
getting a bad grade and you know
screwing up my GPA and ending up in a
bad school so that was my worst
nightmare I'm sure how many of you have
that nightmare oh yeah oh yeah so that
is that is the worst fear and you know
the fear was so deep that even today
like after decades of high school I
still sometimes get nightmares about
failing a math test I have no clue why
but it just comes once in a while so at
that time the strategy I devised to cope
up with my fear is to talk to people who
have similar fears so in this case it'll
be my classmates who have to take the
similar exam I'm like okay I'm miserable
you are also mr. bokade and we are good
right so that feels really good and it
gave me a lot of satisfaction to find
people who have same fears as me and
talked to them
but soon I realized that that's not the
best way to do it because for for
starters first it depends on somebody
else being miserable at the same time as
you so that's kind of mean and second
it's that you're not going to always
find people that share similar fears as
you something that might be scary to you
might not be scary to somebody else so
that's not the best way to go and then I
came to grad school where I was working
on home where I faced probably my worst
fears I was four years into grad school
and none of my experiments worked I was
working on a very high-risk project
which
means that if you succeed you make like
a really groundbreaking discovery but if
you fail you're back back to square one
so I literally lost four years in my
grad school not doing not having any
experiments work despite working day and
night in the lab but it's really
frustrating so I just needed to come up
with a really good way to tackle I knew
within me that I'm going to fail this
miserably and I'm not gonna make it
through grad school so I had to come up
with a way to the hand of the fears so
then what I decided to do was to face
something that is even scarier so what I
did was I decided to jump off a plane I
did skydiving which is really scary it's
really scary but but but believe me it
was so much fun so the view of the Earth
from up above like floating among the
clouds it was just amazing so it was
nerve-wracking but because I put myself
in that nerve-wracking situation I was
able to have like an amazing experience
that I'm so happy about today so so then
I realize that putting yourself through
the worst fears sometimes the outcome
might be more beautiful than you would
imagine it to be and from then on I try
to put myself in situations that are
totally uncomfortable and totally not in
my comfort zone which is happening even
today I am super scared I'm I screwed
this up when I tell you the story but
I'm still deciding to do it because I
know that at the end that it will it'll
make me a stronger person and even
though I feel I know that I would have
done something that I have not done
before so I really it really helps to do
things that are outside your comfort
zone and expose yourself to failing more
and one good way to do it is to take up
a sport you like let's say and then
where you can lose you lose but you
learn to fail but then it's not the end
of it
you don't it's not the worst case you're
still fine so it'll do a lot of good to
you and the other thing that recently
I've been trying to adopt is to try and
understand what's the worst case that
might happen I have a fear but okay
what's the worst case that can happen if
I fail in this and then I realize that
when I do that analysis for the most
part my fears are all to be brutally
honest really stupid like you realize
that the worst case it's not too bad
so recently what I'm trying to do is to
prioritize my fears and
so I realized that not all fears have to
be tackled some of them have to be just
dropped and with time they will just fix
themselves so yeah so this is my short
story and my two cents are just first
pick the fears that you want to worry
about and not really worry about but
face them really with a brave face and
to do that put put yourself in more
uncomfortable situations where you're
prone to failing more and at the end of
it like no matter no matter the result
whether you succeed or fail you'll be a
stronger person in the end so that's
about it that's what I have and thank
you for listening ok so how many of you
want to go skydiving now yeah all right
me too well we'll organize a trip after
this I think it'll be perfect yeah we'll
do it yes so dealing with your fears is
always huge right I'm still working on
this I am what I'm 26
yeah I'm 26 I'm 26 now and I am still
learning how to deal with my fears
because they never really go away they
just become different over time the
things that you're scared of become
different over time and so maybe I will
take her advice and make a list of the
things that I'm afraid of which are a
lot of things you know not ask not for
any for spiders so that's like one good
thing so maybe even like I don't know
fine things that you're not afraid of
that other people are afraid of and you
can like hold that that sounds good
maybe that's advice anyway let's move on
to our next talk um so our next speaker
is part of the outreach department here
she's fantastic
everyone loves her her laugh is
infectious she's so so great so please
welcome our next speaker Oh dollies
I feel like a celebrity alright so I
think most of you guys have seen me
before
so I'm a Dulles once again and so today
I'm gonna talk about my kind of my
trajectory and kind of how I failed on
that trajectory how it made me feel and
how I use that to get to where I am
today so as you may or may not know I'm
actually born and raised in st. Croix US
Virgin Islands you know where that is so
it's a really small island 84 square
miles made up of there are four
different islands I'm from the Big
Island right 84 square miles and on that
one Big Island there are about 60,000
people all right
yes very small and so it's southeast of
Puerto Rico so everyone knows that
Puerto Rico is okay so we're nearby we
have a VI Porto Rico Friendship Day
that's how close we are
and so born or raised in the Virgin
Islands and as you may or may not know
in the Caribbean I'm like one of 90% of
the black Hispanic community I which is
really cool you know I never had mean I
heard about like things of people facing
in the States with racism etc except I'm
like oh yeah that sounds terrible that's
really sad and then I went to college so
I went to college in San Tomas which is
another one of the US Virgin Islands but
instead of 84 square miles is actually
like 35 square miles
right but 60,000 people as well so it's
a popular island and so I went to
college university of virgin islands in
San Tomas and I majored in biology and
so majoring in biology I was on my way
to hopefully become a doctor because
that's what my parents told me I had to
be and so in my senior year I realized I
didn't want to become a medical doctor
but I wanted to do something more and
because I loved science so much I spoke
to my adviser and I say hey you know I'm
really interested in doing something I
don't want to stay home I want to get
away from my mom as far as possible
can you tell me what next step I should
take so my advisor told me
hey you know you're a really good
student if you really love science you
should do what we call a post
baccalaureate program it's pretty much a
program where you go to after college to
get more experience in research and to
take classes so I'm like alright cool
sure it's gonna get me off of the island
I'm gonna go to the mainland it's gonna
be amazing
got into University of Rochester Medical
Center do you guys know where Rochester
New York is cool upstate New York not in
New York City that was my first mistake
alright so got up to University of
Rochester and when I get there start my
classes I realized that now I am the
only black person in the entire medical
center not only the only black person in
my class but I was the only black woman
in my class so you imagine how that felt
where I feel like I was you know on top
of my game at school and in college and
I come to this really large University
where it's a hundred students and I'm
sitting there like WTF what did I get
myself into you and you know just going
there and interacting with people trying
to find new friends I was really
discouraged I didn't have anyone to
study with and the looks that I would
get from people was kind of
uncomfortable and I didn't actually
realize that it was so bad until one day
I went to go to a seminar cuz I wanted
to learn more and I'm standing in line
cuz you know seminars have free food
alright standing in line for the free
food waiting for the free food and a
lady who was manning the food looks at
me and says oh I'm sorry this is for the
custodial this is not for custodial
workers yeah and I was in shock and I'm
like I'm a student why what do you think
I'm a cleaner like that's not cool I
don't even think I told her anything I
was like alright and I kept it moving at
this point I was like I'm in the wrong
place I need to go back home but I can't
disappoint myself I can't disappoint my
parents all right to make matters worse
my first exam is coming up my first like
big exam at the big University I studied
my ass off like midnight I'm up I'm
studying I'm like reading everything I'm
writing out notes I'm like I got this
going to the exam sit down like once
again class of like a hundred students a
week later get a scores what do you
think I did pass or fail I failed
miserably alright my score it wasn't the
lowest score so that was a good part of
my failure but it was like a 30% out of
100 but I think someone scored like a
10% so I was still like on the upper
failure part and at this point not only
do I feel like I'm unwanted I also feel
like I don't belong I've worked so hard
I've left everything I know from my fun
to the island I've moved to her it's
cold and miserable and everyone thinks
I'm something else and I'm that I really
am and who would have moved back home at
that moment I wanted to alright I was
very close to like dropping everything
and said you know I don't think I wanted
um I'm good I'm gonna go back I'll
become a high school teacher I enjoy
educating um you know it is what it is
but I actually took that failure took
everything that was against me I found
people to study with I went to my
advisers I told him how I felt
and what do you think happened for the
next exam I killed and not only was I
able to pass an exam I was also able to
get into graduate school I was also able
to pursue my PhD degree I graduated in
2015 with a PhD in microbiology and
immunology alright I also ended up
teaching medical students I taught
graduate students I taught undergraduate
students and now I'm doing the job that
I love right
so I say that to say this is that
sometimes when you fail and you feel
like ain't [ __ ] here for you usually
that's not the deal think about what you
want more use that as a motivation
factor to make it to the next step and
usually when you get past that failure
you realize that that wasn't anything
like I'm good and everything else ahead
of you you can actually kill it
and that's my sorry whew man that is a
great story yeah so I the best part
about that story is that what everything
was looking down you asked for help
right your friends are there your family
is there nobody wants you to fail
like I want every single person in this
room to succeed and if there is anything
that I can do to help you succeed I want
to do it right so your advisers your
friends your family your peers they want
you to succeed so when you need help ask
for it especially when you're feeling a
little down after repeated failures
that's pretty much how I'm getting
through grad school all right so we have
one more speaker from you she is also
completely fantastic she is also from my
lab the Simon lab and she is just she's
so near and dear to my heart she's
wearing a great sweater give it up for
Oh
Gabriella's Fitz Becker thanks for such
a sweet introduction Kate it's a really
hard story to follow up but I want to
talk about a time that I let my personal
life and my work life come together in a
way that really scared me and how that
paid off for me in the end so this isn't
a story of a true failure but a fear of
personal failure so I'll set the stage
I came to Rockefeller as a graduate
student and I was in a lab that I hadn't
joined yet so it wasn't really like that
comfortable and my turf yet and I got an
email from someone who I didn't know
that well all I'm
that we were both gay and the email was
about starting a group for LGBT
scientists at Rockefeller and I got the
email and I like closed the email and I
had to think about what to do about it
because I realized that I actually felt
I had never thought about the fact that
maybe we would need something like that
I never thought about the fact that we
didn't have it and I felt kind of weird
about being the person to start it um
I'm so thinking back to that time I was
trying to figure out what exactly I was
afraid of and I think my first fear is
that I would be seen as a weirdo like
who is this lady um I was worried about
being seen as a lesbian scientist was
the most important thing about me um I
was also worried that I'd be taken less
seriously like if I was someone who was
really involved in activism for my
community that people wouldn't care
about my scientific work as much but at
the time I thought about the fact that I
felt kind of nervous about this and I
realized that if I felt nervous about it
that really showed that we really needed
something because I've been really lucky
I've faced very little oppression my
family was super great so like if I was
uncomfortable I realized that there must
be a lot of people who were even more
uncomfortable and so I reopened the
email said yes and we started a group
called people at Rockefeller identifying
a sexual and gender minorities prism we
have a really awesome acronym so I
started it with three other graduate
students one of whom was here and a
postdoc and it's been such a rewarding
experience and has paid off for me a
thousandfold both personally and
professionally so first of all one of
the first things I had to do after
starting prism was she one of the things
I was most nervous about which was send
an email inviting people to our first
party so I was sending email from my
email the entire campus including our
president inviting them to like a gay
party people have never met me before
this is the first contact they're ever
having with me there's the first time
they're seeing my name and this is the
first thing they're gonna know about me
but we actually got a personal email
back from the president apologizing for
not being able to come to the party
which was a really great sign and our
first party was fantastic
we had so many people come there were
all sorts of other queer people who came
out of the woodwork and also lots of
other people who wanted to be supportive
so I think my fear of being seen as a
weirdo was really very unjustified and
the other reason that I thought it was
really important to help start prism is
that we realized that we didn't know any
faculty members no successful scientists
who were openly gay and that made me
realize that I had no mentors or role
models who were like me at the highest
level of my profession and I think in
science as well as in many other careers
it's really important to know that there
are people who are like you who were
successful and so we realized that if we
didn't have those people here we were
gonna have to find them pay for train
tickets and bring them here to talk to
us so we've been organizing a few panels
and get-togethers with really successful
gay and trans scientists from different
universities and we get to ask them
questions about their work life their
professional life how things have
changed over their careers how they
mentor students what we can do to help
other people in our community and it's
been so great for the entire University
because people who never thought about
this before are now talking about it
it's not a weird thing it's a normal
thing that we now talk about at work and
also now I know these people and so I
have my own mentors and connections and
so when I'm looking to move to the next
step in my career all these people that
I had to reach out to as a lesbian
scientist now know me they remember my
name I can send them an email and ask
them for help so I feel like the moral
of this story is that you really can't
fail by being true to yourself
[Applause]
okay so we're gonna just take a second
to shift the chairs over here and all of
the speakers are gonna if you guys want
to just come over and bring a chair over
into the center and we are going to now
open up the conversation for everybody
here if you guys have some questions we
will kick it off so okay okay so I'm
going to moderate um great does anybody
have any questions to start off to start
us off
would anybody like to ask a question
yeah I'm gonna say I'm gonna repeat your
question
I'm not gonna walk around with the
microphones as we do normally I'm just
gonna repeat your question and so that
everybody in here is in the livestream
okay yes
so the question is what do you do
if you can't get right back up
immediately and you feel a little bit
haunted by your failures like what how
do you overcome that um good question I
think what one of the speakers mention
is thinking of worst-case scenarios and
also thinking about how much worse it
can be so anytime I do a failure say
like my scenario I'll be like oh it
could be much worse if I drop out and
don't have a job all right
or it could be much worse if I go back
home but it's like ah ha ha you want a
way to go to school you came back in in
finish alright so just thinking about
like the worst-case scenario so that the
failure wouldn't haunt me it'll actually
motivate me to do a little bit more and
also think about like that's in the past
right you can't go back and change it
right once the failure is there all you
can do from it is actually learn from it
and try not to let it haunt you because
if you think about it what can you do to
go back and change it
nothing this is working I usually try to
see if my past failures don't fit like
really haunt me that are like so
stressful like you think about that when
you're falling asleep at night and
you're like oh that time that I messed
up I'm the worst person I like try to
turn that into a funny story that I can
tell other people so like usually those
things that they're so emotionally
fraught but there's also usually
something in there that can be something
that like your story was like so
horrifying but turned into like a really
funny story here it's very cathartic and
I think a lot of painful experiences can
turn into like you can sort of turn the
emotion that you have around them so the
one thing that I also do is to think
about totally something else like try to
not think about it that's easy and
difficult at the same time it's easy to
say don't think about it but try to
focus on something else that you are
more excited about and you know you feel
more positive about then you need not
actively forget something but actively
remember something else and then you
against
you don't want do any more so that's
what I do
I'm gonna echo that feeling I mean it
doesn't anything does not go away
immediately and I guess people here
tonight talking about things these are
all things that happened years
potentially ago I mean my my story
happened yeah three and a half years ago
you don't get to a place where you're
super happy about your failure after it
happens immediately I don't think I know
a human being alive who can fail and
then turn around and be like great
that's just not your response I failed a
test fabulous I've learned a lesson
that's not how people respond but you
just have to gradually get over
something and know that in the long run
people do not remain on the whole
totally possessed by what they were
afraid of when they were you know a
young teenager
most people get over things in fact I
would say everyone does right everybody
grows and learns and the things that I
was worried about three years ago I'm
very much not worried about now I have a
whole load a whole shopping list of
other concerns now so yeah great okay so
um nikka to your left
yeah
okay so this is a question about being
pressured to have high grades by parents
or perhaps other people in your lives
right it sound like my life
it was so bad for me I I've told this
story before where there was one year I
had three bees on my report card and I
cried the entire way home because I know
it's gonna get Lix
that's one no seriously I'm not even
joking and I think it's kind of it's
hard because like you're still under
their roof so you kind of still have to
do what they do but I think if you show
them that you work hard that you're
trying you're still their child and and
I think that eventually they're realized
that and you could also show them
examples like hey you know Albert
Einstein no did it you know fill that
disk but he was like this famous
scientist or he failed algebra in school
like had you can find his of report
cards online they were terrible grades
terrible and not every career needs I
don't think they're very few career
where you need straight A's to succeed
like I wasn't I had like couple B's I
wasn't a straight-a student
alright I still became a scientist and I
think it's people who actually are able
to not get an A and still overcome that
other grade and learn from their field
test and learn from their mistakes if
you're failing consecutively then you
need to get a tutor right and fix the
problem but I think if the first exam we
you know like there was a problem if you
got your way to say hey like you know I
know I didn't do well on this exam these
are the things I'm gonna do to fix it
the next time like I understand you're
disappointed that's not my goal I think
once they see that you're working hard
towards it they're not gonna be so hard
on you important thing in that situation
is being able to keep your own passion
for certain subjects like if you have a
lot of parental pressure it can be I can
sort of take over the parts of the work
that you really like yourself so I had a
lot of pressure and in music so I played
the cello and I had a lot of parental
pressure another cellist out there and
so figuring out how to keep
my own enjoyment for of music alive
while I was also experiencing pressure
for my family was really difficult but
really important because now many many
years later I still have love for my
instrument and I know a lot of other
people who had to stop playing because
they were so stressed out by the fact
that their parents made them do it
so just picking figuring out which parts
of it you actually really like and
remembering that you actually like them
and that it's not just for your family
can be keep you afloat when you're under
a lot of pressure I think a really good
thing is to ask for help because there's
usually a lot of people around you um
who yeah they're not rooting for you to
fail right
nobody is happy when somebody fails a
test right that's not that's not how
people are so I would encourage you to
reach out to people they might be
friends there might be teachers they
might be your parents themselves you
know turn the question on its head
you're unhappy about me getting a B what
do you suggest I do you know can you
help me learn this type thing yeah so I
would strongly urge you to ask for help
from people if you need it great and
we'll go with the question over here I
think it's a black shirt yeah your hand
was up for a while
that's a great question I'm just gonna
repeat it so everybody can hear the
question was about what do you do when
there's someone in your family maybe a
sibling who's set the bar so high and
then you're compared to them how do you
overcome being compared to someone who's
just operating at a different at a
different level perhaps yeah well I'm
the oldest sibling so I feel like I
might not be able to give a fair answer
but my I have two younger brothers and
we're all very close to each other and I
think we could have been competitive
with each other but we decided to do
really different things with our lives
so my brother is applying to law school
right now and he's very passionate about
labor rights so like he also could have
been a scientist but I think he
intentionally wanted to make sure that
he ended up in a situation where we
weren't being compared to each other um
and that's made it so that our
relationship is very easy I think it
would be more difficult if we were
trying to do the same thing and in high
school it's just your grades so it's a
more direct comparison but once you move
past high school if you pick different
paths you can be equally successful and
no one has a way of comparing you to
each other it's not mathematical anymore
so I was eyeballs know I am one of three
I have two brothers one older one
younger yeah the middle which I actually
I actually think I probably have a
diagnosable anxiety about my position in
the family there is such a thing as
middle child syndrome for all of you
people fellow middle children out there
um I think it is a really really hard
thing to do for me a huge part of how I
coped with and actually got over feeling
compared to and inferior to at various
different points about various different
things both of my brother's is to first
of all realize that again neither of my
bro
wanted me to not be good they wanted the
best for me right and coming to that
realization that actually that that
enabled me to have a much stronger
relationship with them I guess
setting aside being able to set aside
any comparison and just be like I'm
really happy that you succeeded at this
I'm really happy that you succeeded that
I understand that you feel a bit
difficult about this thing at the minute
can I do anything to help you I don't
know those sorts of things
uh it took a long time for me to realize
that but neither of my brothers had
malicious feelings about me they didn't
want me to not be as good as them and
they exceeded my expectations when I
spoke to them about my fears and
inadequacies so yeah but I think it's
really hard I think the other thing is
it gets better as you go up and as
Gabriela says diversify because at
school it does it's all a very very well
trodden path and when you branch out my
older brother studied Chinese at
University and my younger brother has
just started University he's definitely
not going to be a biologist he's
probably gonna do like English
literature or something like that that's
what he loves so different interests
emerge and it all gets easier to deal
with I would say I'm also the oldest but
I think my sister struggled with that
because you know she went to college she
didn't finish I got my PhD I'm the first
trial under goody-two-shoes she had a
kid and my parents were hard on her but
I think like I was the older sibling I
had to do a lot of telling my parents
like we're not the same right you know
we are two completely different people
and we're excelling things that we're
both good at like she's good at she has
like our own business where she does
like hair and makeup and she excels at
it I could if I really wanted to I could
probably do it too but but it's not
something I enjoy doing right so I'm not
gonna come
with her to do that and she does not
give two rats poop about science right
so I don't expect her to get to my level
and I don't expect my parents to expect
her to be like you know a scientist so
our biologists so I think just
understanding that everyone in the
family is unique everyone in the family
is different now we're not gonna excel
at the same things and I might fail
miserably at one thing that she may
excel at and vice versa so it's hard I
think when you're in school cuz we did
have those battles at home and not just
between siblings but with the parents
saying that and it's difficult to see
your parent like oh you should be like
your big sis and I'm like I'm actually
not that good if you don't know what I
did but like talking to your sibling I
think like if you talk to your older
siblings I think that's a really good
way to try to you know have them
understand like you know you're
different people and it's not a
competition I'd like to echo odd Ellis's
sentiments I'm the oldest also and I
have three siblings and and I'm like the
oldest by like 12 years so like they're
young right and I and it's weird because
they're being compared to me and I've
already exceeded a were like in
kindergarten when I was in college
that's like how can you compare a
kindergartner to like a university
student is like all right listen so what
I do is I so as they go through their
schooling and they were like well
Jeannie didn't need this blah blah blah
you know I say to my parents you know
you need to just stop this this is every
child that you have is a product of an
individual egg and an individual sperm
cell and it is your fault that you put
those genes together you know and you
have to treat each of those children as
their own thing they're their apples
oranges pears plums you know they're not
things that can be compared so I think
that you know if the I think the older
sibling and my parents are really cool I
guess not make sense you know so I think
that like having you know that the older
siblings sort of kind of like tell your
parents all right back back up a little
bit is a really helpful thing yeah I do
the same thing all the time I tell my
mom was like well
who had her she must have gotten it from
someone yeah
all right let's uh let's maybe pull
something from the middle of the room
Nica what do you think where do you
think all right
wherever Nica pointed okay so how long
does it take you to recover or learn
from a failure I think it depends on the
failure definitely um and it could be
like succeeding at that one thing that
you feel that's so like in science
failing an experiment is like another
one failed right you do it again it
failed and then when it's me when it
finally worked if it worked you're like
okay I'm over it
yeah it just depends on the extent of
the failure it could be like oh I failed
an examined by the next exam if I got a
better grade and I'm over that previous
failure and I think it's harder when
you're young or two because there's so
much pressure especially in school to
like get these good grades and get into
these great colleges and you have your
teachers and your classmates and your
parents and I don't think there's a set
time I can't say and it it definitely
doesn't take like a day it doesn't take
like a week but I think like putting
your energy into something else like
someone else mentioned to try to like
not forget but like don't let it be on
your mental that heavy I think it's a
good way to go at it and I would just
echo that and say I think it depends on
your mindset as well it did first would
depends what you fail I mean I failed my
driving test and I was mercilessly
bullied by both of my brothers for being
incompetent but and that actually took
quite a long time to get over as I said
I've failed three experiments today and
I'm not that bothered by them I know
that I failed them all the time and I
will be able to rectify it somehow next
week but I also think it depends on how
you interact without failure do you
obsess about it torture yourself about
it and I think that only prolongs how
long it takes you to
you move past things so being generous
to yourself and saying okay you know
that didn't go so well let me see what I
can do differently next time or let me
try and throw my energy into something
else those are really good ways to speed
it up and there's not the best answer
but if you just have one failure at a
time you're you know constantly
obsessing about it but as you grow older
you will realize you have multiple
failures at the same time then then it
doesn't really matter then it's really
fast so when you are young it takes a
longer time but when you grow old it so
just wait better life gets better when
you get older I know it seems like
there's no tomorrow but trust me there's
like 15 years down the line we'd be like
I'll stress it over that boy that didn't
want to kiss me doing nothing now life
gets better like don't stress about it
all right let's all right next set of
questions okay Joe are you still working
on the lactose no I gave up I cut my
losses
but I will say um that I do think
similar you know to it and actually I'm
now working on so I'm now in a cancer
biology lab so I work on something that
I think is more meaningful than my
little travel bag lactose detectors and
I think also in retrospect I got a
little bit overhyped and overexcited
about it so yeah but no I'm not still
doing it
okay so we are talking about
misconceptions when it comes to failure
so what are your thoughts on the
misconceptions pertaining to failure
well I'm a perfectionist so a
misconception that I have always had is
that it's possible to not fail it's not
possible
you will always fail you can't be
perfect and something that I so I
mentioned before that I play cello and
so when you're chill a performance is
like a really scary thing because you
have one shot and they're people
watching you and you're doing a really
difficult physical activity and it's
really hard not to mess up a little bit
and really really great people mess up
all the time and so I got a piece of
advice from a cello teacher that has
been really helpful for me and he said
you always will play one wrong note in a
recital and you just wait for it and
then you're like oh there it was okay
and that's been like really helpful for
me for so many things because you can
just be like oh there's you know what's
coming and so it's not um it's not gonna
surprise you you just see it you're like
oh there it was alright maybe now I
don't need to have another one but I
think the fact that you can avoid it is
a misconception I had um I think another
one is that failure is bad like it's not
necessarily a bad thing I mean unless
it's like three exams in a run and you
don't pass a class but like especially
in science like I remember feeling like
for months I was working on one
experiment and I was like I can't be
this stupid like I'm doing everything
right like I'm following the protocol
all the papers say that this is the way
you should do it it was like a new model
organism that I don't think much people
have used worked on this one protein and
like I was basically like I'm I'm dumb
and this one this one other scientists
from like Canada I guess came across my
name and a similar project and he's like
hey like I've been working on this
experiment and it doesn't work and I'm
like word mine doesn't work either we're
not stupid it's the parasite and so like
that actually
led to a discovery that for some reason
this particular protein were unable to
express in this particular organism
right so in that sense that failure
actually led to us understanding
something else about that question that
we had and I think a lot of times people
feel like you can't get past that
failure is gonna haunt you forever
it doesn't like everyone fails every who
in here has not failed before right so
like there's no like perfect person
there's no perfect way like we all have
to fail in order to get to where we're
gonna get to in life and I like to think
like everything happens for a reason
failure is part of life like do it and
get over it
I'd like to echo that like my
misconception was that okay what will
people think about me if I failed I mean
like what will my parents think what my
friends think you know I'm I'm a loser
no like each of them go through the same
amount of failure they just don't talk
about it that's it yeah so don't worry
about what others might think if you
fail so I just wish everybody would talk
about their failures a little bit more
honestly I mean I I don't know if you
guys do anything on Facebook but I had
been on Facebook for a little while and
everybody is an or Instagram and
everything is like totally like perfect
and beautiful and photoshopped and you
know I'm I'm a mom and I have kids and I
try to work and like I see these other
moms like posting these things about
like these like like 75 layered birthday
cakes and like these beautiful and I'm
like oh my god I can never do that for
my kids but then I realize it's like
that you know but they're like they have
teams of people helping them or or you
know everybody's sudden photograph yeah
no seriously it's not really no no and
so it sort of makes you feel like
there's this like people that live these
perfect lives but it's so not true so I
feel like hey if you can share a failure
on a daily basis you're helping a friend
you really are
alright let's go in the front we haven't
yeah okay
so what do we have three more okay how
do you cope with failure so how do you
want to keep it pg
[Laughter]
my one of my coping mechanism actually
like as soon as like a failure hits is
music I love music like I I wake up my
alarm goes off I go into bathroom I turn
on the radio
alright I shower I play music you know
I'm walking on the train I play music
I'm in the lab I'm listening to music
like that's just like my my out no
seriously music - uh yeah prove its to
me it's good music and so I think like
finding a way that you can cope at the
moment and then when you're ready to
face it you're like alright I guess I
should like go back and try to figure it
out but I think my one coping mechanism
is through music um I find that gallon
tubs of ice cream work really well but
you're intolerant I usually take a
shower or like a bath like that's my
like it's it cleanses the failure off of
me and I can think again ice cream would
be a disaster ya know I mean I'm I'm not
lactose intolerant and it yeah it's it's
not the ice cream it's just being in
like a cozy nice environment I watch I
get a movie curl up in my bed and eat
something usually is what I do
and then you know go to bed and it will
be better in the morning because it
always always is I just got a puppy it's
a really great I know I'm telling you
it's a little it's a I've rescued her
from Ohio from like a puppy mill it's
like a lab hound mix her name is willow
she's adorable but that's for me I mean
this is new but I uh
every time I go home and I know it's
been a hard day where I like totally
messed up a bunch of stuff I like go and
she just
like licks my face and I'm like oh it's
better life is awesome so if you can get
up if you can convince your family to
let you get a puppy and then just like
keep getting puppies it'll all be okay
all right here we are
can you speak up a little bit are you
able to hear
okay
yeah well that would be a very scary
situation but the nice thing is that
there will be I think it this kind of
thing there will always be at least one
other person who really appreciates that
you put yourself out there and if it's
the kind of sort of environment where
there isn't a lot of support the one or
two other people or maybe it's even more
than that who really appreciate that you
reached out we'll find you and you can
team together so like if we had not had
a successful reception by the university
I would have still met three or I would
have met other people who were in the
same community as me and we could have
banded together and supported each other
and in that type of environment it's
even more important so like my high
school was a lot less supportive than
Rockefeller is now until finding those
few people was very valuable to me at
that time as well because we could keep
each other safe
how to be a perfectionist that's a
that's a really good question it's a
really hard thing to balance all the
time but I think acknowledging that your
personal happiness is also really
important and that you can't do your
best work if you're stressed out and it
can be hard if there's family pressure
but like I know some people stay in in
the lab like super super late like I
know that if I'm sleep-deprived
I can't do good work I will just be
dropping things so I have to go home at
a reasonable time and eat a healthy
dinner and exercise and stuff like that
so I feel like because I'm kind of a
perfectionist I can justify taking the
time to take care of myself because I
know that it's necessary to also do good
work like I was someone who
sleep-deprived can't do well on a test
so you're not helping yourself by
staying up late studying at a certain
point you just have to get eight hours
of sleep I think time management is like
the biggest thing and I didn't really
understand time management until like
college where in my mom didn't wake me
up to go to class and I had to study on
my own and you know I have to get to the
class to pass the class and it's
something that you're gonna learn as you
get older in ninth grade I feel like I
was like the toughest year I think like
just transitioning into high school
trying to figure it all out how to fall
into all these classes like how my
friends doing basketball and football
and choir and get an aids like when do
you study like do you have a life but I
think like learning you know I'm gonna
set aside an hour each day as soon as I
come home I'm gonna spend that hour in
this subject because that subject is
closer than the other subjects so just
even getting yourself a calendar and I
do it all the time I use I have like
three different calendars have a Google
Calendar have an AI calendar and I have
my notes all right and I also tell my
fiance like hey can you also remind me
on this day so I can get it done I think
like those you know gentle reminders and
you know keeping track of everything and
I am I'm like a post-it chord and so
like every day I'll come in I was like
okay what's my to-do list
des and I write them out and I put them
in order of what's most important what's
least important and then I go off the
list and I give myself like okay if I
finish three things I can go on Facebook
for five minutes
all right no seriously it's like kind of
like treating yourself you know so you
can get things done and then I am NOT
leaving work until sometimes almost
times I'm not leaving work until
everything on this list is you know
ticked off so writing list time
management get in a calendar just trying
to balance everything and then you also
have to decide like what's more
important to you like maybe you have to
get rid of an activity when I was in
high school I was in choir I was in band
I was in the Spelling Bee and then I
realized like I have to drop something
cuz my grades are not suffering and then
so I think I drop spelling me and then I
you know did the choir and about cuz you
know music is life for me um so what
makes you happy what's more important
how can you balance everything that you
love and still maintain those good
grades but it's gonna take time you're
not gonna you're not gonna get it um I
think that I'd say two things the first
thing is everybody goes through a period
in school or at least that's what I tell
myself cuz I certainly did where they're
unhappy and not balancing things and not
managing their life exactly as they wish
that they were that might be not doing
well academically it might be not doing
well socially it might be not doing well
in a combination of those two things it
might be sports that you are not doing
well it could be anything but everybody
goes through it
and everybody emerges out the other side
of it so know that and then the second
thing that I would say is I am a little
bit like Gabriela a perfectionist and so
for me a big part of it was learning to
sometimes take the pressure off if you
can honestly look yourself in the mirror
and say I've been working really hard at
this then maybe you just have a break if
you've not done anything then you
probably don't deserve a break
but if you if you can if you can
honestly look yourself in the mirror and
say I've been struggling with this all
afternoon or all weekend or all day like
I need to look after myself I mean he
should not continue bashing my head
against a wall specific advice for being
in high school and wanting to have a
social life and also do well in school
is that I had just the nerdiest best
friends in high school like I was
friends with three other girls who all
ended up becoming doctors and they were
so great and they all had really strict
parents and we would hang out and study
together all the time and it was we had
so much fun we were so goofy but we
worked so hard and we all did really
well but we like kept each other in line
but we like got to hang out a lot
because their parents knew that we were
also getting a lot done that's a really
fun thing all right so last question and
then we have some activities put
together for you guys outside all right
do we have any projects that what oh
projects that we've completed and are
proud of okay that's a fun question I
like the ending on this thank you for
making it positive well aside from the
horrible object lactose bio detector
misadventure I yeah there's lots of
things that I've done that I'm proud of
I graduated I just graduated in June I'm
very proud of that so proud that I've
decided to spend another five to seven
years to graduate again so I'm very
proud of that I'm proud of decisions
that I've made so I think about
priorities that I've had people that
I've looked out for I had one friend in
high school who went through a really
really difficult patch and I looked out
for him and I was his friend when a lot
of other people didn't want to be and I
look back on that and I'm very proud of
that so I think you can be proud of lots
of different things they can be material
achievements but they can also be thing
that only you know about so I would say
I take equal pride in those different
sorts of things um I'm proud that I
cleaned my apartment last weekend joking
but not really I'm proud that I cooked
three days this week at home I'm proud
that I wrote a thesis on my own and I'm
proud that I graduated that was in my
story all right I graduated twice and
I'm proud that I made it in the big city
right that was an ongoing project and
hopefully I can stick around until like
I'm tired of paying ridiculous rent and
then I moved to the south like everyone
else yeah I'm proud of graduating as
well like I had a tough grad school like
for five years I had nothing to show for
and my experiments we're not working it
just like kind of usual but yeah towards
the end it all worked out so if you just
give it time I realized that many things
fall in place so I'm so happy I made it
to grad school and I'm proud of it I'm
proud of getting into grad school I'm
proud of being healthier now than I was
in high school like I exercise and eat
way better than I did when I was younger
which I think that's an accomplishment
um and I'm proud of having a really
healthy personal life I guess I'll
answer to so I'm proud of the fact that
you are all in this audience right now
I'm proud of Ravi bu and I'm proud that
we as a university who has been fairly
closed off to the rest of the world is
now opening the doors to the people that
deserve to be here in addition to the
scientists that are here so I'm proud of
you guys so thank you
all right so I hope that you all have
learned a little bit about failure and
how failure is not equivalent to bad but
failure is actually a thing that can be
embraced and can be used for moving
forward if you don't fail you don't grow
so that's an important thing to remember
moving forward I'd like for you to
continue keeping in touch if you'd like
to come and join us outside we have some
activities some things that you can feel
that really easily but then if you keep
on practicing you'll be fine
like origami so we have a bunch of
things if you guys want to check it out
there's good directions and if anybody
has any questions about rock edu or
programs come find me okay or me or Orin
Ellis yes and thank you so much